[Musique]
quand on parle de cyclones terme
français en fait on parle de plusieurs
choses
la définition d'un cyclone qu'est ce que
c'est c'est simple c'est une
perturbation météorologique qu'un centre
et des vents qui tournent autour
toujours dans le même sens sens inverse
des aiguilles d'une montre
mais ça ne dit pas si les vents sont
forts ou pas donc cyclone ça veut pas
dire forcément vents très forts dans la
famille si claude il ya des dépressions
tropicales dépression tropicale c'est
quand effectivement il ya un centre les
vents mais les vents qui sont en gros
inférieur à 60 kilomètres/heure donc
c'est le premier stade du cyclone mais
c'est une dépression tropicale
deuxième stade du cyclone si le
phénomène se renforce les vents sont en
gros entre 60 et 120 kilomètres heure
on appelle ça une tempête tropicale et
là on commence à le donner un nom à
cette tempête alors qu'avant les
dépressions uniquement un numéro on va
dire dépression tropicale numéro quatre
numéros cinq tempêtes tropicales on lui
donne un nom comprendre une liste qui
revient tous les 6 ans si le phénomène
se renforce encore
ça devient un ouragan et c'est là
souvent qu'on fait là qui peut la
confusion entre ouragans et cyclones
ouragans c'est le cyclone qui a beaucoup
de vents puissants en général les vents
sont supérieurs à 120 km/heure et bien
sûr peuvent dépasser les 200 voire 250
km donc c'est ce terme ou à gand souvent
qu'on confond avec le terme cyclone
pourquoi parce que dans notre bassin
atlantique et caribéens
on dépend d'une appellation anglo saxon
puisque le centre responsables désignés
par l'organisation mondiale météo c'est
le centre américain que vous connaissez
le national hurricane center qui à miami
et donc on a francisé le terme tropicale
cyclon en cyclone